el hombro de biden surge en un período
real para una posible subida negociada
del conflicto
creo que este hombro brewster es el mejor
un insulto calculado por parte de Biden
tiene entonces tiempo en ser uno de los
improvisación para la que buydens
bianconi con sitio cerca de la casa
blanco
se mantuvo la importancia en el spa de labios sucios
entonces tienes que servir un serio obstáculo de pared para el
negociar y regalar esto
La situación es difícil y triste y un rincón.
rania parte de la critica seca
sawai del bidente ami un poco religioso
que entonces todo para entrar estaba en
nichols en irak tiene autoridad moral es
fue despedido inmediatamente de la carne de hierro un
putin cena haz un ejercicio de la
revisión de la política de guerra los
último ios
menos claramente
de rango de la guerra en irak para mejor
Damian un error porque basado en
información diente renzi a los militares que
resulto arkin al falso aunque es mucho
diferente a lo que esta pasando e
andre rusia y ucrania
muchos ios la invasion de lucia la
nación de la península de crimea y lo
extensión
de la población es ahora un verde de la
guerra que prácticamente usarla
civil es como el blanco del sat
hackers para diferenciar y mismos los los
estados unidos tubos garza y ​​pensamiento un
error comi rac1 significa pedido
desconciertan la invasión de Ucrania en este
momento y que papel sea capaz de curar el
presidente francés emmanuel macron ento
tuviste que profesor negociaciones con rusia
para pasar el verano
el presidente macro por supuesto tiene
encontro muccio y nene se escucho
durante su última semana saber
sitio como la cabeza de puente del
diplomacia europea
sin embargo
está cantando sobre
gansu bryar el tamaño europeo como
presidente del consejo de europa
el saber muy tenso que la finca metas
promedio si eres
entró de
aumentar para mejorar
desestabilizar una relación personal
como un líder ruso
ultimamente completado y activo
bajos creados para el ascenso del poder
de tambien la marca de alemagna y ne
siempre pasado eso fue explica monseñor la
interlocutor de putin con el sindicato
La Unión Europea tiene para que la marca macro sea la
tratando y ocupando y lugar
del marcador
mantiene el parecido y se estira lo suficiente con
Rusia